foreign
comes from Trish in Missouri our son
graduated from high school in 2021 he
decided to use his scholarships working
income and a small subsidized Federal
Loan to pay for college so far he has
done an amazing job with his finances he
had 17 700 saved for him in his 529 but
he wanted to leave it alone and use it
for his later years of school when he
might need it even more the 521 529 was
doing so well we neglected to look at
the funds he was in and move it to safer
funds as he got closer to 18 years old
it grew to 18 700 by 2022 but has
dropped significantly to 14 800 as of
today we realize now this was a mistake
now with less than three years of
college left the market still looking
Grim do we move it and cut our losses
tell him to use it all that he can now
or just wait it out also Missouri where
our 529 is as of right now will not let
us use 529 to repay back loans later
thanks for the advice Hmm this is
interesting I I feel like the first
thing I would do is just kind of talk to
you guys about your mindset I mean
you're saying that he's taken out
federal subsidized student loans so far
and that he's also doing great with his
finances I think the fact that even debt
was on the table to begin with isn't
great you had a 529 available and then
you still took out a student loan I kind
of would just challenge you first and
foremost to go let's let's not do debt
like let's first establish that mindset
and take it off the table and then
explore options from there I think if
that was kind of a conversation from the
beginning you probably would have used
the 529 earlier on and he wouldn't have
taken out a loan
um but Dave I'm curious about your your
thoughts on this because we're never
going to tell you take that alone
exactly period okay so now we got to
figure it out because here's what taking
out a loan is in this situation if
you're taking out a loan so that you can
leave this alone and let it come back up
that's like saying I'm going to borrow
14 800 hoping and invested in the stock
market hoping it will go up
well you would never do that that's
Dumber in a rock
and so no we're not going to do that
we're not going to take out a loan in
order to give this time to ride back up
what we are going to do is put Junior to
work
yeah w-o-r-k
I want him busting it and uh I want him
you know using Christina's materials and
applying for scholarships like a
bazillion of them
I don't aim to apply apply apply apply
apply I want him working all the time
and um
then the other question I've got is
where is he in school
you know is he in an expensive school
you can't afford so in other words if
you want to leave this money alone and
let it come back up which is a good idea
actually
the only way to do that is find the
money to pay for school
because three years if he's got three
years left that's a lot of time he's
gonna come back up right and you got to
find the money anyway because this is
not enough to get him through school
well and if they continue going forward
with the way they're going forward three
years of taking out loans is going to
add up to a lot of money like you're
saying that it's a good he's done well
with his finances so far but three more
years of taking out loans that's not
gonna be good so it's amazing the
creative options you come up with when
you take debt off the table he's going
to have to maybe look at what school is
he at can you go to a cheaper school is
there some sort of employer he can work
for that has a tuition assistance
program what scholarships are out there
can he talk to the financial aid office
and see if they can offer him anything
else like when you don't have debt as an
option then you really start fighting
for yourself and trying to figure out
what are the most strategic ways for me
a ton of these retailers like Target for
instance and others are if you're
working a certain number of hours
they're so desperate they're willing to
pay tuition
legit and so yeah go that that and that
changes the numbers on what you're
making while working there I mean you
might be making 18 you might be making
22 an hour and getting free tuition
potentially 1000 thousands of dollars in
tuition like that is a lot of benefit
right there plus you're building your
resume I mean you may be starting in a
basic retail position but maybe you can
be a manager by the time you graduate so
if you're not going to borrow any more
money for the next three years you've
got to figure out how do I pay a way to
pay for college anyway
so it while you're doing that that gives
you also time to let this money grow
back before you cash it in yep because
I'll tell you that in 12 months I think
you'll be fine it's gonna be back
that's my guess might be 18.
might be 18. but bear markets there's
very few bear markets would have lasted
longer than that when you start this
process the spare Market started
basically at the first of this year
and a four-year bear Market is almost
non-existent in history there's almost
none of them
and so you know two years you're going
to be fine 18 months you're going to be
fine something like that you're going to
make some money on this money but the
the point is you've got to have some
money anyway to get through school
without debt and so we need to go find
that money from working from
scholarships I went for work
scholarships whatever it is we're doing
and from school choice uh and so forth
so you've got a lot of work to do period
across the board and the book is debt
free degree it is in the Ramsey store at
ramseysolutions.com and it will help you
with this process and Austin if you can
figure out who this person is and how to
send it to them go ahead and send them
one okay I don't know whether what our
connectivity is on all these questions
that come in by email and other things
so but if you can do that get him out
get him one out I'll get her and one out
I guess and but yeah the
it's almost like uh we're doing good
with our money while we borrow student
loans is as dumb a statement as I don't
have any debt oh wait I've got student
loans yeah that's debt
it's just those are both dumb statements
now people keep saying that student
loans it's good debt and people just
seem like that that for some reason God
people are starting to realize this bad
debt I mean it's so bad the president
has to forgive it
but still keep giving out loans yeah
well thank you for that that's good yeah
and she you ruined the whole thing there